you remember like when you were a kid
and you were on like a BMX bike all day
and you know if you went off a jump and
slam down the seat oh yeah and it kind
of vibrated through your body it's like
that all the time though no it comes and
it goes you can feel that through your
body yes bro sometimes I feel it in my
back and then you have to have a doctor
finger your ass well here's okay well
here's what's up they take well that's
just for half that's for fun
sometimes I just go in he's like you
don't have any symptoms like I don't
think it's not swollen at all yeah what
oh well you want to make it swollen get
out get out
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Music]